[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round three of the
Spring Classic here in st. Louis late in
the round grandmaster Verico pian shook
things up with a drawing King and three
versus King and three endgame one
mistake by Grandmaster Roman Edouard and
a Cobian one what looked like a study in
the B group International Master Jaken
Bulli AK threatened mate on grandmaster
Victor Michael F ski with a queen and
rook battery gaining a point for the
Ukrainian the weekend begins but the
week for these players is just beginning
coverage of round four starts now with
over $30,000 in pride on the line 20
international chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2018
spring chess classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for the 2018 spring chess classic
this is round number four of nine in
this round robin event my name is Ben
Simon and I've rethought a namer
and we have a little bit more clarity in
this tournament so far before the round
began today we had three names at the
top in Group A and one lone name in
Group B but before we get to today's
matchups let's take a look at what
happened yesterday in Group A here are
the results as they happened only one
decisive game but it was a big one right
so we had a four draws as same check and
drew Darius roots and remain Edward a
lost of original Cobian Alex Denis took
Jurgis Lazaro zone Yara's arable drew
tsuya Ganguly and Jeffrey Zhang drew
Alex epitope and Coby and when he came
down here after his game he was he was
kind of disappointed we weren't on the
air anymore because he's like I gotta
show you this take take a look take a
look it was a totally drawn ending and
he came through and what looked as he
said like a study like a composition and
so one mistake by Roman Edouard
and vara Cobian was able to capitalize
and that brings us to our standings as
they are right now
or before the round rather and you'll
see we have three names at the top yeah
we have Alex and Owen is sugar playing
against the illusion of carbon and
Jeffrey's young all of them with two
points we have a few players to the
point and a half and also with the
points as you can see we have all those
close margins and by the way Alex Andy
shook is playing right now of Illusion
accordion so they might be playing for
for the top seed yeah I think that's
definitely a fair assessment now on the
other side of the room we do have a
challenger section or a group B which is
still a very strong group this is
strongest classic we've ever had here at
the club and yesterday let's take a look
at their results for groupie
yes whether we had two drawers Alexander
fear drew Akshay Chandra PD drew a
wonder Liang and three decisive results
and I go is b2 the black pieces out
Aaron grab insky and melech catch Ian
and Jack stem black bits with white
pieces JJ Miranda and Victor mihailovski
it was great to hear from Melek
yesterday one of the friendliest guys in
this tournament to be short and this
brings us to the standings after three
rounds have been completed in Ruby yeah
so it looks like Akshay Chandos so far
still on the top with two and a half
points and after him we have entry
antonov it's on the second seed and we
have a few players with the point and I
have one point and a half point as well
lovely lovely and now the games going on
right now at us chess champs calm are as
follows let's take a look at group a
pairings two games are already over in
these pairings you see Sam Shanklin vs.
Roman Edouard that game is a draw and
then also Darius spirits and Alexander
eepa table have drawn their games but
there's three more still going right
that's nice breakfast so if the second
goodie pingas Jeffrey Zhang and les
arbres own is still painting as eligible
and we have original Cogan playing
against all its own issue and can you
say game of the day oh yeah and it comes
to these two look at the scores so far
both are still undefeated in this event
and it is a tough event like we said two
and two
let's see if we can get a decision here
and someone will take the lead here in
this tournament Markovian vs. Alex
Dunphy and by the way they are also
pretty good close friends so that makes
that match up pretty difficult for them
emotionally probably to play against
each other how do you handle that
whenever you play a friend in
environment like this well you know what
Sam is just business yeah we've been
doing this a long time here well yeah
you gotta have it adjusted time here the
spring classic sometimes when you play
your friend you call them by the wrong
thing you're so close
okay let's take a look at the at the
pairings in Group B if you will thank
you alright and in this division we have
really lucked out today because the last
four games you'll see there are still
having a little bit of a relay problem
from yesterday so those games you'll be
able to see after the fact that us chess
champs calm play them through you might
have some good happenings there but the
game of the day in this division we
lucked out vitally because it's gonna be
on grigorevich versus victor mikhalev
Sookie you took a look at this game
earlier and had some you were kind of
impressed oh yeah definitely it is
there's gonna be some some fighting over
there I I so that's one of them didn't
castle and we saw some long castle so
it's gonna be pretty pretty interesting
match to look at yes and we do have
access to this game we'll be taking a
look at it a little bit later on and now
a fatality I have to ask you what are
your predictions for today
oh thanks marshal ask me I've been oh
well as you can see today we are both
wearing the red color and I think that
we are going to see some file on the
chess board today some fighting
definitely fighting chess fire yes it's
definitely love okay yeah we're we're
collaborating here this is really great
I appreciate it
alright the tournament format it's
pretty easy to understand we have 210
player round robins the time control is
90 minutes for the first 40 moves and
after that each player gets a bonus 30
minutes added on to their clock there is
a 30 second increment from the very
first move that'll make it harder to run
out of time in this event and also there
is a 30 move draw rule in effect which
means that the players cannot offer or
accept a draw before blacks thirtieth
move and that will encourage fighting
chess
oh yeah that one really draws okay let's
take a look at the prizes for group a
this is what they're all playing for
folks with a twenty-two thousand dollar
prize foot on the line yeah the first
place is going to take with him a 6000
dollars and then a second and a fill
place are going to take four thousand
and three thousand dollars and this is
the rest of the break up and Group B is
not to share
itself with a 14 grand total prize fund
and the individual payouts listed right
there
right so first place is gonna take with
him four thousand dollars and twenty
five hundred four put a second place and
two thousand four the third place and
still everybody gets a prize okay and
now let's get to the games Battaglia
let's take a look at one of our games of
the day first of all I want to check
that out oh yeah definitely
so the game of the day today and that's
dealt with a group a a Cobian and ona
shook the good friends in u.s.
championship competitors going back
years and years vara Cobian actually was
the 2014 US Champion runner-up it was a
very very close playoff and he lost to
gana calm ski after making in the final
very very intense situation so this
should be a good match oh yeah
definitely so let's see so as far as I
can see not right now we are in the end
game the pawn structure is a bit a
little bit different for both of the
players
it looks pretty equal to me although
this de-spawn might be look looking
handing but the knight Canada I'm not
sure if the knight can take this pawn on
d5 because if you if he does then the
white rook is going to come out here
swinging on d1 and although the black
guy can take another poll on c3 then
white will be able to recapture on d6
check and I think this looks too
dangerous for for black so black should
probably not capture this pawn but I
wonder if black can play this move b5
and open up his position now let's see
let's see where from the beginning what
did we have how did we get to this
position so we had d4 Knight of 64 e 6 9
f3 and b6
okay so we have the Queen's Indian
defense a pretty popular opening we have
nowadays a to preventing the bishop for
coming to d4 and pinning all night
Bishop to a6 Queen to c2 c5 okay so this
is pretty much all dealing d5 very
distinct idea pawn takes d5 20s d5 and
now black played this move g6 now for
our viewers at home just remember the
night the knight cannot take you on on
d5 because white has this very strong
counter move with Queen to e4 check
checking the king or and also checking
the check in the night now even though
black can go back with the night then
the Queen can recapture here the Queen
they work on a 8 so it's a very nice
little trap that yeah even in the
opening version Cobian said to Alice
handle an issue well obviously it also
pretty experienced players so a little
did nothing the pod
play g6 with the idea to fianchetto his
other Bishop Knight Ct was played Bishop
to g7 efore
Bishop takes F 1 and now King takes on
f1
very strange yeah so why does why does
white need to make this white needs to
make a choice in this position do I play
a 4 or do I play g3 and faint chatter
the bishop on g2 but probably white
considered that the idea is that black
can put his after d6
castle and rook e8 there might be some
pressure on this epon so sometimes white
is not so happy with this bishop on g2
because it is just stuck upon looking at
this Pony 5 so many times we have even
in the bodoni we have this exchange
efore bishop takes and King takes on f1
and basically now after the six many
times what white is doing is that he can
play g3 that's a castle
and King to g2 and this is what we call
an artificial castle rook e8 and rook to
e1 so even though we're losing the
castling in one move we kind of do it
manually and it's better than nothing
yeah exactly so now so let's go back to
the game after d6 was played Queen a 427
Queen d7 9b to d7 it looks like all of
our players like to play in games we see
more and more end games a very
interesting style bishop therefore now
this Bishop on f4 is getting his job
done here on the floor attacking this
week pawn on d6 and Black has to play
King to e6 so now both of the players
are without any castle but it's okay
because we are just in the beginning of
the end game and we know that in the
endgame we need the King in the center
anyway so h3 was played a six blacks
idea is usually to do some to gain some
more space on the Queen side with this
pawn b5 and white obviously played a
four-night to e8 so the night is coming
to c7 to support the b5 pawn we had a
few knight moves five few exchanges hero
I decided to do exchanges Bishop just to
get this beautiful square for the knight
on c4 rook to b8 rook to e1 97 in King
to f3 rook to e1 so I think that the
idea of rook e1 is probably to bring the
other route to e1 to double up the rooks
and to invade on e7 so yeah if you can
see it's actually white to move right
now so let's let's look at how black
played black did play b5 according to
our prediction and looks like
version is virus thinking here if it if
it will be up to me I would just just
snap the spawner of the board and
context and now I would just go try to
find a spot for the night now the idea
of exchanging to a four-pole that the a
6-point
is basically it's probably a little bit
better for why because the stroke might
get active on the a file maybe we might
see we're going to a seven or a six so
I'm not so sure why is this paying so
much time but no he actually did make
him open they did take on b5 as you can
see how this initiatives coming back to
his game I'm pretty sure we're going to
see a takes b5 pretty fast looks like
Alex on issue does have the advantage on
the time with 34 minutes versus 10
minutes and they are at move number 25
yeah so if I will be on virus shoes I
would probably try to play a bit faster
so we're going to get back to this game
it looks so far it's pretty equal but
this is the game of the day you never
know what's going to happen yeah it's
super important for the standings you
know they're there they just played a
few moves here huh okay wish I would
have seen one on the fourth day there's
a slight delay in the relay of these
amazing dgt boards it really is a
technological marvel you think back
decades ago I mean you have people
relaying the moves by hand and now you
have these digital boards sending the
moves to the worldwide audience I think
this is right even even if you're
thinking about the clocks I mean we
didn't have any digital clocks we had
those analog clocks and not only are
these digital clocks but they're
plugging into the boards sending the
time out too so that's really needs them
that's pretty amazing
so I think that after both took on b5
and var has played night to e3 coming
here to attack this pawn on f5 and
defending his pawn on d5 now overall I I
mean I like White's position it
his pieces are a little bit more active
I think this this rook on a one feels
very good the stroke on e e2 might
become active this pawn on f5 is a bit
shaky and let's not forget the Kings the
Kings are the Kings are in the in the
endgame so the probably white wants to
put his King on f4 and then try to get
again get this this pawn at five I think
it's going to be interesting and by by
the way that the VAR was playing
yesterday his endgame which by my
prediction it was supposed to end in a
draw it was imposed to is this logical
prediction yeah so yeah you never know
what's gonna happen okay so let's go to
the game of the day and it Group B we
have a victor Mecca Levski play playing
black pieces against Andre corabeth's
okay while is going on here as we said
White's King is on e one still in the
middle and blacks King Castle I don't
really like the screen on a just aligned
in front of the blacks true but let's
first first of all count count the
pieces what is going on here so yeah it
looks like white is pawn up and seven
points versus six pawn so hmm wow this
is gonna be what is this just just me or
everything is hanging like like the
knight on d3 nitin before everybody
everyone can capture everybody I mean
all those people all those pieces are
just hanging a - the knight the bishop
here Wow okay let's almost looks like
looks like a bughouse game it looks a
little weird yeah I don't even know like
my mind's like I don't even know where
to begin yeah exactly
let's see let's let's go over it step by
step d4 9 of 6 Bishop to f4 ok so we
have the London system d5 Italy Bishop
to g4 ok
idea attacking the Queen f3 Bishop goes
back to the 7 hmm interesting maneuver
some people might ask why why did why
did the Viktor made this menu why did he
go to g4 and then go backwards it
doesn't just lose time
well there is an interesting idea here
is that if black would play Bishop d7
immediately while night King just white
can just develop his knight to f3 so in
this case this move Bishop to g4 and
after white plays f3 well that pawn
honestly basically takes away that
Square from the knight very very tricky
prompting the f3 pawn to inconvenience
white later on reality
oh so 93 was played c5 okay pawn takes
25 then Queen takes off of Queen
a5 okay he wants to take the pawn back
on c5 Queen d2 knight c6 very
interesting okay preparing a 5 probably
broke d1
and castle long castle Wow
very sharp play very sharp play by the
players as we said that's that's that's
some file on the board over here 19 g -
e - so this this white is trying to
figure out how do I develop my pieces 92
and an e5 very active game by victor i
think i think that he lost yesterday his
game and if it so maybe it just shows us
how he wants to come back Bishop to g5
Bishop 3 6 9 2 c1
and now d4 so black decided to explore
the center night to b5 night - before ok
why can't we take the poetry hmm well
then probably let's see what what I can
do here you can maybe take the Queen on
a5 or huh so this was White's idea after
playing Knight to Knight to b5 so white
wants to exchange Queens because this
King is still in center but Victor says
no way I want to keep my Queens on the
board let's see 9 to be 4 by the way the
threat is Knight takes on C to check
because the Queen is basically pinned
the King cannot take on c2 because of
this pin over here pawn takes 24 and
Bishop takes on c5 Wow haha so this is
how we got to this position so black had
had so many options here you could take
on d4 he can take on c5 and he can take
on c2 with a check tough tough decision
pin City yeah so he decided to take away
this on c5 which I actually I really
like this one because it no you gain a
pawn back and also I developed my my
bishop and I connect my ropes
like blacks position now and now why
played this move Knight to D 393 was
played and now it's a victory is
thinking about his move let's see what
is your thinking what can we probably
okay so our number one candidate who
will be just probably just stabbed at
night of the Portland III because the
immediate threat is Knight takes on c5
and 9 takes on e5 what else can we do
here with black
I wonder I wonder if Victor is thinking
about something very very courageous
thing maybe like a rook ht8 and take
maybe take on D for now when I move my
bishop somewhere and then it's going to
be a discovered check the problem is it
a white can probably just make a simple
King move to have to it suddenly became
feels very tough alone enough - yeah
that's not that's not a castle for the
game that's like the king is sleeping on
the couch so yeah it's going to be
exciting to see how how black continues
in this position after Knight to d3
let's check this variation 9 takes did
they check bishop take some d3 ok so
again if black if black can always
exchange the Queen's but I don't think
that this is what the victor wants
because once the Queen get of the board
it's gonna be much easier for y2 to make
a draw so how do we keep the Queen's on
the board I can play Bishop before but
then I can just play c3 I don't like
that option so much
maybe he has to take so take Rock takes
and now black is going to take on
default upon and in this position looks
pretty equal to me right now
maybe maybe white will castle and then
we will see a castle finally yeah it's
very unusual
just move number fourteen right now and
still why did not guess on now we know
that you know why it makes the first
move in chess so here's the one who's
supposed to Castle faster in this case a
black has alongside it's interesting to
see and again by the way and look at the
time we just mentioned that they I
removed number fourteen they only have
about 10 minutes so ten minutes for
Andre and 13 minutes to Victor they have
to they have to make almost almost two
limos 27:26 moves in ten minutes that's
it's outrageous I mean they get they're
gonna really have to start moving
quickly how are they decide they wanna
they want to play blitz today instead of
a classical chess hey let's let's just
let's give it some time and then we'll
we'll blitz it out to get to move 40
yeah where they get an extra half hour
on each clock but yeah 9 to 12 looks
like there was a move played on the
board I think there was some kind of a
capture yeah there was nine things d3
check was played I'm pretty sure wife
has to be captured with a bishop I don't
see any other way if we can if you
capture with the pawn that black can
always play Bishop to b4 and finding
that Queen pretty sure that the bishop
has to take on d3 yeah and this is what
was played Queen things do to check and
now probably you wrote things d2
would be the move that I would play
actually I saw Bishop takes right Bishop
takes some tea - well you know me mostly
don't like going backwards sorry so
Bishop takes on D - was played I wonder
what is the difference now vortex or
default will probably be played and
let's say Y it will Castle here I think
it's a black is fine I mean this pawn on
d4 gets black the the space advantage
and probably route
h3 yet or something like that and I
think I think that is fine also there
are some ideas that thing a6
let's see so interesting game
interesting game alright maybe we can
check some other games yeah let's go
ahead over in Group A we still have
three active games and we haven't looked
at Surya Ganguly and Jeffrey Zhang yet
so let's take a glance at that game yeah
so Jeff is on right now he's leaving and
let's see what is going on so Jennifer
is playing with the back pieces and so I
can do is playing with white so far it
looks pretty equal this pawn on d4 is a
backwards pawn black is trying to put
some pressure on this pawn or the other
hand white luckily the black spawns on
here on b5
let's see what what can be working why I
do what probably my rock on a one can be
improved question of the world I put
this the stroke on you one I have so
many ideas Rudy one Roxie one probably
even look to be one it's all depending
depending on the plan I can either put
the pressure on v6 I can either defend
my pawn on d4 or I can try to invade on
the C file there might be another idea a
plan like roof to e3 and oak to f3 maybe
to try to attack this point of seven but
I doubt this is going to happen so so
far it's looking to me pretty equal the
knife will probably jump to d5 to block
it at that pawn so let's see let's see
how did we get to this position so c4
was played as the first move c5 we have
the English defense already d5 Knight 85
this is all pretty much actively Bishop
to b5 93 context III Castle 64 okay so
white you got a handle in the center
with the spoon d4 we have lots of
developing moves
efore GT so far so far I like how white
is playing and getting some advantage
here take stakes and b6
you should be seven takes with a few
exchanges here
96 Trudi 85 and Knight to c8 yeah this
this this night this type of disease is
a criminal we can't leave him over there
so that's why you should really work in
that term every day I would really
appreciate it if you could call one of
these chess pieces of criminal every day
continues thank you
so night night take some eh and queen
takes on Yeats yeah so if this is the
criminal maybe the nighttime sees is the
policeman right
is this fair assessment yeah night 88
Queen take c8 in a fate a very
positional game again I like I like
White's position is slightly more his
beasts are definitely a bit more active
but the question is how do we make
progress with white and there were a few
moves that were played let's see what
happened in the game
we need Queen to b3 was played putting
some pressure on the basics pawn rotates
d6 d4 Rotex b6 and now it is black to
move so Jeff is move okay so let's say
just going to exchange the ropes and now
his rook is hanging and the pawn is
hanging on a5 so how do we how do we
manage to defend both of them or we can
either play rook a4 but if we play okay
for I'm scared that white can play
something like rule D 1 and then we have
some back rank mate threats that knot
won't be good for black the other move
it would be about Queen a foe also leave
the background exposed so maybe is only
option is to play Queen to d8
and after 28 basically to offer a queen
exchange quinten's d8 wrote hd8
look looks pretty equal to me those
players are just too good
let's see I think that rotates bishops
was played in the game Queen takes Queen
takes beat six is going to be in the
game and yeah looks pretty cool yeah we
we see the so we are taking that rope
and I think the Queen d8 was played and
now the question is will Surya exchange
the Queens or he will try to leave them
on the board maybe playing something
like queen a7 or queen a6 maybe the
queen from here puts put some pressure
on the on the rope the pawn and the
night so it's hard to tell right now
all right so this was this game let's
see some other games you know we haven't
really talked too much about Surya
Ganguly and I I didn't know him before
this event 35 year old Indian player who
actually I just learned this he was part
of team Vishy Anand
as far as vichy seconds going into the
world championship defenses 2008 2010
and 2012 he was a part of that team and
those were all successful defenses for
Adam who only lost the title in 2013 -
who else Magnus Carlsen so that's a
pretty cool fact they're from Surya
Ganguly now is a plane in st. Louis yeah
it's pretty impressive by the way for
the viewers who do not know a second
it's almost like a coach so even even
the top tank chess players in the world
like you know Magnus Carlsen and Vishy
Anand and all the top just players even
though they're the strongest in their
field they still need somebody to train
with and this is what we call a second
so usually a coaches somebody who is
high rated right but obviously probably
Mexican culture fish you can call each
other people but you still want to train
with those people
so the the goal of the second is trying
to play some some games practice games
and maybe even then try to find some
theoretical ideas theoretical novelties
for those players so it's very important
well you still need a strong player -
maybe not replicate but to work with it
right and and of course the best players
are playing against each other so you
can't get them yeah exactly
so yeah so so we will see we'll see if
so yeah we were able to spice up the the
game over here
let's look at some other games what
about the yellow star visible versus
bruise on yes that is the last active
game we have yet to look at what is
going on here okay so white
at first I thought it's why these three
pawns up but then I did but then I think
it can be possible that he just clip-ons
up so apparently white has three pawns
for a knight
so black has night for for three pawns
and pretty much you know the night is
worth play points they play pawns so it
almost seems like a draw but I can
promise you this will love your dress
this is my prediction okay okay no draw
here no Joe no draw in this in this
position I think that I mean that the
the pawns are quite quite scattered I
mean look at those troops on the e-file
I think that black has a very nice
blockade on d5 actually I really like
blacks position
I mean without involving the piece for
the take pawns but I really like Beck's
position and I think has pretty good
chances to complicate things and in in
this in this game I'm not sure what
would be his next move maybe to try to
capture on e5 or maybe to try an attack
may be something like H 5 H 4 but I
think that yeah we'll try to to find the
way to his first win in this in this
tournament it's pretty interesting let's
look at how this this position happened
what happened in the so we see again d4
by the way everybody is playing d for
this round it's it's funny how things is
to go in and out of fashion in Chester
yeah so defo and c4 is kind of I guess
more fashionable in this dilemma
yeah we had GT Bishop g2 d5 Queen to a4
okay so we have some development here
Queen to Bishop g4 how would assume both
players came prepared
it was pretty much like Theory c5 so the
idea that this move c5 is actually
pretty important we see it in all of
those structures like wants to exchange
side con for a set up on on d4 and
that's not giving why this huge
advantage in the center we need for
Bishop to e6 and Queen takes b7 okay so
here goes the first pawn let's start the
counting how do we get how do we get the
three pawns night to before
so basically black it says okay I lost
upon but I get the initiative 9 2 g 5
Bishop c8 24 pawn takes pawn 3
takes why there's still only one point
out but now black plays d5 with a threat
on the night on g5 and I defended okay
h6 and now nice take of seven look at
that so why can't the night go back
probably because now black if there's
something like a bishop of five and to
get the initiative I mean this time in
HD is is so passive we usually don't
want to put our pieces on the edge of
the board especially not the Knights
it's very difficult to get them out of
there
I don't know when these things will come
back to life so maybe this is why it was
it was probably a difficult decision for
white here to say five is the Queen
totally trapped there and not exactly
trapped because she could probably move
some of them somewhere back or she will
back okay yeah I you probably you
probably it's probably because of me not
back with moves right make anymore in
fresh never retreat never surrender yes
so that sees a knight takes of seven a
very interesting sacrifice why'd he
why'd got to add their two other pawns
one okay we have some maneuvers with the
pieces Queen to d2 was played let's see
if we can refresh the board and see what
happened then so yes so after Queen d2
like d2 85
he is trying to expand on the Kings side
although I think that the white king is
pretty safe and now I can route to c1
huh a very very interesting position I
don't see a way how can how can black
get the advantage the problem is that Y
does not have any major weaknesses I
mean this pawn on d4 is isolated but I I
doubt that black and easy to attack it I
mean the bishop is defending it the
queen is defending and yeah it's I think
it's gonna be messy I mean something
some tactics is gonna go here it's gonna
happen and definitely we it will be good
for us to stay tuned for this for this
game so for sure yeah definitely one of
the ones to watch okay let's look at the
how how the draws will figure that today
let's look at Sam Shanklin order against
Edward Romain I think that Sam had all
draw so far right yes Sam has drawn
every game thus far
I mean he's undefeated yeah she's good
yes I guess so the draw master d4 d5 c4
so we have the Queens gambit accepted
that's when the black accepts the
sacrifice on c4 III 86
see five castle so basically white looks
like white develop all these pieces but
now black gains a few tempos and I'll
defy I think this is an important move
by trying to create some kind of a
counter play a bunch of exchanges see
black does not take with the night it
doesn't does not want to exchange Queens
because maybe he wants to keep fighting
a 4 B 4 B 4 and the rook to a - hmm
that's that's an interesting movie of
rook a to probably the idea is to push
BT and swing the route to D - D - I
wonder if it's if it's just a bit too
slow
I wonder if Y I can play something like
e 5 and you know maybe sacrifice I
really want to see this file being open
so ok it was played route to d8 b3 Rudy
- ok are the few exchanges
26
finally black castles it looks like
black is not worse here I mean it all
depends on this opponent c5 sometimes it
can become a witness sometimes it's a
strength it looks like we had a few more
exchanges here coming in yeah I would
say it's a pretty even game change
take and their gates for a drop probably
because the RO could just take on a four
and that is that it's just a draw
now compared to the game that vara had
yesterday for the Kings here we have
also two rooks so the rooks is most
likely to be a drop yeah we can just
swing the ring around just a wait black
does not have any weaknesses now if you
take a take of the rooks of the board
well white will probably have these
style advantages his King is a bit more
in the center let's see a probably
probably close to a draw so yeah
and the other game between daro spirits
and Alex eepa table which I believe was
the first game that ended that was a
draw as well group a how did this happen
alright so that's it so as I see in the
final position what we have here is in
opposite side opposite color Bishop
endgame and in such end games it's
usually going to end up in the joy it's
just those bishops I just think they
can't fight against each other so all
right I think they're on different
planes of existence different dimensions
I can't talk to each other they can't
fight nothing I see draw no eye contact
no so yeah so basically the idea for
white is that white can just place his
bishop on c4 and black cannot make any
progress I mean not black not white they
cannot make any progress those bones
will just stuck these pawns on all the
Kings side they are also pretty stuck so
it's quite understandable why they
agreed for a draw let's see how it
happened again we have a DD fall as the
first move okay this this opening is
called the Catalan when white is
venturing his Bishop on g2
this has been much old theory usually
Black has the option of taking on c4 but
then white would probably regain this
disponible thing something like Queen a
495 or Queen to c2 so black decided okay
I'm just gonna play it safe just to play
a c6 and then he developed his Bishop to
d7 that's a pretty standard idea and now
he took on c4 we have 95 few changes
this is actually all looks looks pretty
pretty theoretical to me this is move
number 15
we have a few exchanges again b5
pay for
so why does did get the control over
that over the D file but not not much
you can do with that
I assume that blacks idea will be just
to exchange all those tropes of the
world yeah so this is pretty much what
happened and now Plex idea would be just
to exchange the queens and left IB
before and it's a dropped by the way for
example even if Blackwood played this
move c4 and even if Black gets to this
kind of an endgame even upon down even
this is considered drop a pretty easy to
draw for black top meant to make again
because of the opposite color of Bishop
and games so good good game good game I
think that there I think that all the
players came very prepared this time
yeah and there's no reason not to be you
know a round-robin situation you can
study up on all of the opposition and
like we said on the outside a lot of
these drawers just means it's closer to
perfect chess
yes that's if chess was a solved game
one would think a drop yeah did you know
that the the checkers is a solved game
by the way I did know that you can play
a checkers engine it's night without an
engine Chet
checkers database online and you're
never gonna beat it it's the best if you
do as a draw and you're not gonna draw
yeah yeah so the final is also draw
right if both players white and black
they play perfectly I would assume it's
supposed to end in a draw it might be a
win for the first player that moves I
don't remember it okay you know it's one
or the other yeah but hopefully it will
never happen the chest
what if chess will get sold chess is so
deep
right you can go backwards and forward
with chess I mean you have billions of
of options in checkers you can only go
forward so you have finite amount of
moves in checkers in chess you can go
backwards well remember you can keep
well that's a yeah
and now I'm just being told someone said
that it's a win for the second player in
checkers whatever I can go to Wikipedia
and look at it yeah yeah and I'll leave
a comment on the whole YouTube channel
yeah say these guys are morons I don't
know checkers is a win for the referee
you know come on I don't know but yeah
it is interesting we meet solved game
it's there is a database that exists for
every possible position in a game
whether we're talking about Connect four
or checkers and theoretically in chess
you have to start from the from the end
of the game in chess and work your way
with more and more pieces and as you do
that exponentially become such a mammoth
operation just to store these positions
right that's getting solved in our
lifetime
we have something close in chess and we
have the Nally move database the endgame
database yes and so I think it's up to
five pieces maybe more you can do the
free version that's available online of
the endgame table base and you can just
google it you can do up to six pieces
but you can't do five on one situations
I'm not sure what that's all about
so all these pieces ganging up on a can
can't do it don't have those positions
but all other six game and game table
bases you could borrow Kobe ins position
that he won yesterday you could put that
in a table base Mike it's gonna
immediately show the result yes well you
know matin 359 there's some crazy
positions it's really fun to play with
actually the game table base do you have
a 59 is a fun thing I wonder if how you
don't get the 50 move rule and draw them
well that's the thing it doesn't take
that into account so in practice yeah
the 50 move drug draw rule would be
invoked 50 moves without a capture or a
pawn push either player can came to
claim a draw but in the world of table
base you can go a little bit longer yeah
sure sounds like fun thing having moves
it's probably gonna take
like a baby they're so crazy but Andre
corvatz and Victor Meehan Lipsky our
game of the day in Group B they're
getting into some strict time trouble
but let's let's look at that in just a
bit here Batali and take a break for a
moment okay let's go get a coffee or
something we'll be back here in just a
couple minutes for the rest of the round
for analysis of the spring chess classic
[Music]
[Music]
the question on Twitter from dumbass I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like ba3
is an illegal move here because white
advances for two squares not one but it
still is something we call hustle and
you can do that I get to do it instantly
you can't wait for a move
I played sake play King in seven kimchi
- because y'all play four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
the playing during the course of my
steak yeah he told me this is excellent
g5 this was what I was kind of hoping
for because now I think we practiced
Noah Lawrence
this is not how chess works certainly
would be much much more fun if just
actually work like this I don't think it
does well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me
and what's worse I will never hear the
end of it my quality of life has just
gone downhill tremendous me because I'm
actually sharing the office of the guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Mike Matheny whether you play chess
for fun or want to boost your child's
academic performance come visit the
Chess Club and scholastic Center of st.
Louis right here in the chest capital of
the u.s. from a welcoming diverse
environment to a Scholastic outreach
program now in over 100 schools our
Center across from the world chess Hall
of Fame the Central West End has it all
so whether you've played for years or
never before we invite you to experience
all chess has to offer there's a weekend
vacation on Montague trip in a nearby
city you won't wanna skip
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get advice from
the best and even challenge them to a
battle be the best chess player you can
be it's time to level up your game with
just 24 Premium Membership
and we're back here in st. Louis for the
2018
spring chess classic we're in the midst
of round number four my name is Ben
Simon and I thought I named her and
we've had some developments during the
break
vitaliy well what should we look at
first all right well let's look at the
game of the day in Group A goobie and
victim s collapse key vs. Andre garbetts
it will left it saying okay well they
exchanged the Queens and it looks like
they Victor D take on t4y played before
trying to fight for advantage the bishop
went to b6
a 4 so even in the endgame we have some
kind of attacking chances here that he
used to play obviously a5 and pushed
this bishop backwards
that's why black played a 6 a 5 okay did
we see yeah we did see lots of exchanges
here 9 to d5 coming to snap this pawn
bishop takes b5 of 90s b6 which are
going back Knight to c4 Bishop f4 so we
do see that the king did come to have to
be 5 rook HD 1 now King b7 was played
let's see I think we had a few other
moves played and then wipe with h4 and
black played the move h6 hmm now they
are moved number 26 and they have only 2
minutes 2 minutes on the clock so this
is pretty much 2 minutes for 14 moves I
mean this is like 30 seconds to over
yeah I mean it's they're really getting
down to the wire here 12 moves left to
time control g4 and king b6 was played
here
six okay okay so I wonder who has the
advantage now and Bishop takes c4 so
takes e4 okay that's a big decision to
take I have to change that the bishop
for the night and I wonder if black will
take with him with the pawn or the
bishop well if it takes with a bishop
with him then he might lose a pawn
that's look at this take take take on
the floor well luckily for black he has
this move man
rope - E - I think you can take on c2
now just as a reminder if we exchange
both blocks
we're gonna again get to this opposite
kind of Bishop endgame draw right yes
without we don't want to see a job oh
it's a file on the on this the chess
board and so let's see what has happened
why did not take on what D taken C folk
like D take with a bishop and now white
played Bishop to e5 and this is a pretty
good move that is to attack the g7 Paul
and d4 pawn
[Music]
Vitalik big development here going on in
group a between Surya Ganguly and
Jeffrey Zhang it looks like Zhang is
about to win this game here yeah and
they are and Ganguly is really low on
time
yeah let's that's a dead game I think we
should definitely glance over at Group A
here for a moment
wow it's far when we when we left this
game that Jeff is queen Iroko all the
way not developed so what has happened
so we left in this on this position and
this is where I said that the black did
like Wendy eight and he offered the
white the exchange of Queens and
basically white had to figure out the
way exchange Queens and kind of get into
a Jewish position or keep the Queens on
the board why I decided to keep the
Queens on the board and I wonder if it
it was if it was the mistake of the of
the game to keep it cleans on the board
I know sometimes we we just want to win
too much and we're trying to spice the
the position too much and that's
actually not too good for us because
we're missing some some things rookie
for was played 95 broke a four so what
is going is going for this pawn a five
but I wonder if black can find very
unique Cantor play when this Bishop on
if they is kind of hanging around this
King is not is not defended at all so
let's see what happened Queen d3 Wow
very nice attacking move attacking the
bishop and rope to a tree yeah now I
feel like the the white pieces are not
working together I mean the Queen on c5
those pretty good
and let's try to figure out what can be
Black's next move
well that's for that stop for the first
candidate vote which I'll checks Quinn
b1 check let's start to check it on b1
King G 2 is pretty forced and how can we
continue then I'm sure there is
something here maybe something like
Knight to g4 attacking this bishop very
interesting now also suya has only one
minute on the clock and they are to move
number 38 according to this and let's
see I think there was a move played AHA
and black played this move Queen to e1
put some more pressure on the f2 pawn
let's see what is the idea is the idea
maybe again 9 to d4 and tally well we're
considering this we have an update on
our dark games in Group B I do know that
Akshat Chandra and priyadarshan canna
pan have drawn their game as well there
was a decision in Turkish Grand Master
JJ a lemur on D his game as he defeated
Jack stamboli AK so a lemur and a
congrats to him hopefully we'll be able
to talk to him not sure yet but yeah
it's all coming down to the wire here
yeah yeah it's it's good to know it's
gonna know and so in this game looks
like so yeah has 35 seconds I mean he
needs to make a decision he needs to
make just two more moves to get another
30 minutes on the clock but it's a very
tough decision to make and then you have
up to 30 minutes to look at your
crippled decision exactly and make a
decision so 30 minutes to suffer yes
and so at Queen t1 so so yeah I decided
to snap the
a-five pawn off the board and a wand Oh
what happens after ninety three check I
think this is this was Jeffrey's idea
this was his plan
this is what we called in Chester poison
point as far as I am pretty sure that's
pretty poisoned now ninety will come do
becoming King to h3 now white will have
is forty moves done but let's see if we
can somehow get the king check on f1 he
has to go to h4 and now let's check him
again with a knight that's that's what I
call the hunting season yeah
so the king can go to g4 or g5 but I
gotta say I mean I don't even know let's
try let's tie g5 but then there's h6 ooh
maybe in this version why I can try to
pick King to f6 give any tricks there
are normal checks and actually maybe
white is the one who wants to check my
black with the rook e8 and then Queen f8
and so on look at that
but unfortunately for white this would
be after Geoffrey would get another 30
minutes so I'm sure pretty sure that we
are going to see we are going to see 93
check King H thinking Queen to f1 we
will see this on the board I'm pretty
positive and then Geoffrey will have to
think about how do I continue how do I
prevent this move King to f6 and
and then we have to we have to talking
about other working g7 so what what if
black tries to play King g7 C
okay so yeah it looks like this game is
gonna be pretty exciting
after King g7 yeah it looks like black
is just letting this move h6 almost made
almost made and then the Rope comes to
d4 check the king yeah it looks looks
pretty pretty bad for for right now okay
so we would like to welcome one of the
grandmasters ajju Von D and welcome to
our show thank you very much and you you
walk today right yes congratulations and
you warned against AJ Jake's 10-block
that's right now fortunately we did not
see the game live but maybe you can tell
us a little bit about about the game I'm
sure we prepare for the game right and
well the parents were up where I was
like two weeks ago
and with coach Alejandro Ramirez we had
checked some of my opponents games but
we couldn't really prepare move by move
because he used he was playing a lot of
stuff so we decided to play the trombone
ski eventually but I think I already
mixed the move order and like move three
after Bishop g5 nice it was slightly
embarrassing yeah I had two midterm
exams this morning all right after the
midterms I just came without checking
another line and my opponent played
actually what we have expected but I
just haven't refreshed it in the last
two weeks so nice so you just just
relied on instincts I guess yeah but I
actually blundered a few poems and I was
probably worse all the game but turned
out lucky at some point now you know you
are from Turkey but you live here in st.
Louis right yes
I am from Turkey but I study in st.
Louis University I'm a sophomore so it's
my second year nice what's your major
I'm majoring in Computer Engineering Wow
Wow very interesting yeah so your
sophomore very nice very nice
how do you like San Luis so far but
pretty much probably they did bit more
different than Turkey right well
definitely it is different but chess
wise and school wise it's everything is
perfect I'm very happy to be here and
looking forward for the other years to
come nice nice you by the way you
English is pretty good thank you very
much yeah all right so maybe you want to
show us some of the moves of the game
yeah all right so the juice 34 mm-hmm
Knight of 6 mm-hmm Bishop c5 c6 normally
I play d4 but this came we prepared an
ID - so I stick to that mm-hmm and c5
was my opponent's choice and they
already confused that I think normally
it's probably e3 but I play d4 before
because as far as I remember there was
lines with e4 but I think that's after
a6 Bishop h4 included ok so I play d4
here he took on d4 the deep a pretty
fast no he was very surprised after e4
because I was blitzing out the moves but
he thought it was some preparation mmm
actually confusion
very nice psychologic yeah chansik i
play d5 and of course the big difference
between 86 and Bishop age 4 included he
has Queen age 40 Queen 85 years and he
played it I say so there's something of
a pin here yeah okay Knight of 394
Knights to e4 yeah now he's attacking
the bishop and threatening Queen takes
d5 ideas so I played Bishop at 4 Knight
c6 Bishop d3
feel like black is already better night
takes D to Bishop takes Bishop before
yeah so so far he's a pawn up he's a
pawn up and it's a very strong pawn if
we go for some endgame he can break with
f6 and stabilizes d4 pawn mm-hmm
so after realizing everything went wrong
after the opening and the worst thing is
I can lose I just took on beforehand
because my other option was to play a
three and after Bishop d2 Queen d2 and
to suffer the same game
right which is pointless with white so I
played Bishop takes before good decision
takes and I played c3 because at this
point I just want to castle and hope for
some some counter play let's hope for
the best
dc3 castles short sacrifice that as well
he took on B to rugby one so I'm three
pawns down but he has an on Castle King
and still has to develop a few pieces so
I was kind of counting on that yeah this
this Bishop on C a thought I have some
compensation compensation of these
practically right
he played b6 I think it's very good move
because if he would Castle there are
ideas like Bishop h7 which I am not sure
if it works but it might be working some
day after takes 95 maybe not necessarily
here but maybe in the future future
great gift sacrifice yeah anything can
happen on an undeveloped Queen side so
b6 I played rook e1 I'm defending my
pawn on e5 and maybe wiki for ideas
mm-hmm this should be seven and 95 so I
want to go 94 or something like this
yeah probably to probably not to take on
h7 yet no maybe I want to play Queen age
five or something like this I'm
attacking those
she's definitely winning probably queen
of four yeah you need the problem in
such positions for black is that he has
so many options
that's very true yes and you never know
which one is the best in a practical
game yeah if I we spend a lot of time
yes the correct approach and lost some
time and eventually got into time
trouble so here I played 94 I thought
this is nice because I thought he missed
this trick after Queen takes e5 I have
bishop basics which is which is winning
the Queen not necessarily I'm better
because he takes it on a 696 King g7 and
after all these exchanges if he takes I
take so that's okay but King is serving
seven I take it 95 probably like it's
still fine but at least I have some
counter play good night
yeah how do you how does it take their
roots out it's okay yeah it's gonna take
a while and at least I'm not dead lost
as it was probably before fine so he but
he castles here so that was actually not
the problem with him he actually saw
Bishop e6 he so he cancelled here yes I
played 96 which is probably not
criticized but I think he has to play
Ruby eight or 95 here as we have just
discussed with him
he played Knight takes e5 which is very
interesting I have to say I'm sacrifice
yeah sacrifice the bishop for more
initiative rather than crammed pieces so
the best of the best move was maybe a
route to VA just to defend a bishop
aside I think so it was better
from my perspective because rookie for I
don't get anywhere he can just go to 86
with his Queen and he's fine I guess so
maybe he has to play this but I'm still
having some counter play probably maybe
Queen g5 I go have 4 maybe have five
ideas eventually you're gonna think
that'd be time take it I'll be two
points down and I'm still playing not
resigning yet
yeah I have chances and we shall see
so since there will be decided second I
took on b7 it makes sense because if
this he is trying to release his pieces
right after a while so he played 94 I
think that's not very accurate either
play at age 3 I think that's my only
moment attacking everything yeah queen
f2 not very sure how precise these are
because King is one and he played them
all which I was not expecting at all he
played at five which is very crazy if I
take here's like Queen h4 and then FG
always threatening g3 made so I'm not
sure how I defend that I think I played
the only move here Bishop b5 because my
idea is I want to take on d7 and then
take on e6 and in some lines my bishop
was coming to h3 blocking the mate on HD
in some hypothetical lines but probably
not so wrong I think like somehow has to
settle for a draw by finding it but if
that rook c8 a c8 yeah rook see Toruk
see 3 some ideas I took on d7 of the
Queen Queen ok he played Roxy 226 very
sharp very sharp we shall see God very
tactical and he was under a minute or
two so I was taking my time because I
had more time than him looking h8 play
Bishop e2 yeah
and I think here he panicked he had to
play Queen g3 but he took anyone oh it
took it took only one yeah rook takes
Brooksie one Bishop d3 I thought this
was actually drawn 8f - so it's kind of
defending against a promotion night have
to check that this was actually a Dragon
Age 2
he took on d3 Queen takes of five and
nice he probably has to play rook b8
here which is draw I think people look
fc8 trying to see yeah
so initially I thought this was a draw
after I play rook f1 he goes eight six
and he holds but then I realized they
have 96 and they played this because I'm
threatening night c8 and here the main
problem was v1 Queen which he didn't
play and after that I was gonna play I
can take night c8 or actually I have
night of 7 check this was very nice like
that
sure and King G and 95
I thought this was winning you look down
but your wing yeah he has no checks and
the funny line was 95 we can play
covering matron 87 and Queenie 6 I think
I gave check here yeah King yeah a
knight of seven I think here it's meat
oh okay
we can't take the knight because of the
28 change a this model made yeah but I
have to first take the knight on e5
because 925 cover right but of course
this is actually not necessary to do I
have many other wins and though I was
actually going to play this but maybe
you actually can go King f8 actually
after so maybe this was actually
unnecessary can get paid I think he's
fine here because the Queen on the one
defends eight seven still looks very
dangerous for him yeah yeah I probably
have to be precise okay say instead of
promoting to a queen he played Knight
takes you one nine takes a one night c8
h 597 now if you promote b1 I just take
one age 5 and then Queenie ate an egg
right so he played Knight f3 check I
took it with the pawn because my god my
queen covers everything yeah even H if
he gives check on h1 I just take it and
if you just resolve you
well nice congratulation it looks like
that the game was very tactical yeah
very tactical very complicated and I
don't know yeah do you have any any
advice for our viewers at home you know
how to how to improve your tactics you
know any a drills or exercises you're
doing any puzzles or just play that well
I just play a lot of blitz games I guess
and I like sharp games so overall I just
like hit tactical and try to attack as
much as possible nice and there next
next game you're gonna play again
you know okay well congratulations again
for your way then the good luck in the
next game and we are going to actually
interview another teammate of yours from
from your school and yeah watch the
yellow star variable so if you guys want
to join us let's look at his game what
happened
so yay love game let's see what happened
in that game
there's this game okay okay so that's
not what happen in this game so default
was still in during game 912 6c 4g63 c6g
to
and and then d5 all right well here with
us we have you eligible thank you for
for joining us today
congratulations for the win yeah thank
you I know that you're also famous in
st. Louis right you're studying here at
SLU yeah I'm local let's see nice nice
so so tell us about about this game I
assume you prepared a little bit no I'm
serious I was like well he could play d4
he can play it for three can you play C
for I'm like no I'll just go work out
and you know just relax and have some
fun whatever
yeah looks like it's the best cure for
the day I think J Jamar and he also said
like just oh yeah it was a different
case he just burned every bunch of pawns
an isolation so say it so the game so
who did d4 just Knight of 6 she's 6 g3 I
said this is pretty much called t OE 4
as well as a theoretical line and the
normal move here will most frequently
plate I believe is night of 6 to g7
mm-hm and then C takes d5 Knight b6
Queen d1 and then C takes d5 and that's
well in the game is a relatively boring
well it was like slight pressure from
white and then believe Carlsen plates
like this a couple of times and the
general crowd to just picked up this
line and but I don't see black winning
this game so I just decided to go for
something more fun because this position
okay maybe I make it draw off to like
some struggle you know but it's just no
fun to play yeah so you play for the win
well I just played for interesting chest
nice nice
so to Bishop g7 C 35 I actually was
thinking if I should play a short Castle
this is actually a possibility but I
just couldn't
at all I mean I briefly looked at this
well kind of it's a joke actually
because like what if I just give up a
pawn yeah but but I just couldn't
remember like D takes c6 Knight c6
Knight f3 and then I would say 97 looks
like an interesting novelty yeah and if
III than if five that's good for black
but I just couldn't remember what if
Queens you want instead of III mm I mean
it's it's maybe it's playable for black
I'm not sure one's a okay so interesting
but I couldn't remember so I just took
in g5 and it's also playable it's way
more interesting than see tonight ft-7
and might be six oh right you know so
Knight takes Knight f3 the knight has to
go to b6 can you just is it
there's a difference if you just Castle
here I think so yeah there is some
difference someone good sure what what
is it
okay I just want to kind of define his
queen right away no I'm live here you
should have played Queen a3 but I'm not
entirely sure this is just my
speculation I I just think so when a
three the ideas that I don't have this
Bishop GeForce and he's just sex the
pawn and queen only three is actually
guarding I mean just looking at Easter
and forming some lines like after Bishop
g5 I don't know just something like that
I see it's hard to know what the creator
god yes somehow somehow I wasn't more
afraid of 23 but Queen c2 and I think
this is yeah it looks a harmless for you
right keep developing yeah I developed
so many pieces so the middle game was
was pretty exciting right so he just
develops a few pieces c5 was important
right here
the Queen efore maybe this was maybe
maybe he had to understand that this is
not better heal anymore and baby tried
to exchange a few pieces maybe taking on
c5 I mean this bishop on c1 is yeah but
then I wasn't sure like how exactly DC
rook c8 maybe Knight e4 I mean it might
be three let's say I can't even go with
say 90 d7 and no it seems like a simple
game for what yeah yeah it looks pretty
good so I mean probably probably about
equal anyway it's just not enough I have
to give up the light square bishop some
point and take him c5 and white should
be I should be okay but yeah that's
probably the best way for him to play I
think he just missed Bishop e6 well
based on his really long thinking after
this one spend maybe like half an hour
yeah and I got to relax I have a queen
takes b7 so I assumed that it was all
planned
yeah yeah before yeah so that's what I
calculated and after Queen if for once
you reach I mean after Queenie for
actually I'm great but 95 yeah and here
I started having multiple glitches just
many of them really okay so Bishop state
I think is forced and then here I wasn't
sure maybe I should play well I honestly
just missed it I mean I forgot about C
takes D 483 I just forgot about 83 if
not 83 I'm probably just winning and so
can you play maybe Bishop a5 first and
then Elizabeth 5 maybe Queen h4 h 6 but
then D takes d5 and here I just don't
embarrass myself if I say too many bad
lines you know and here is like looks
very complicated mistake mistake
I missed a nobody takes d4 is okay but I
just had a glitch I was kind of mad at
myself that I completely forgot that he
has a three and I'm like yeah
how can you be so naive you playing
Brazilians just thinking that you're
winning like after 12 moves yeah I mean
like that's just not the way life works
yeah so he puts up a fight I absolutely
think you have to go back I wasn't I
wasn't so sure eyes well I kind of
wasted lots of time calculating G takes
c3 Queen before plum takes on g2 and
here actually she probably can't even
take was the Queen
yeah I'm not sure what I was calculating
here and then I thought even like h6 oh
wow and it seems like I was just
calculating this for fun not for any
practical reasons which I live all day
if Bishop a 1898
so 94 and I'm like what if I go Bishop
h3 in the h3 38 yeah yeah and here if I
move the rope yeah and then like Queen
g5 was my idea was they I mean followed
by f5 or something but this is I'm not
sure why I was calculating this doesn't
look really looks like him yeah I mean
white kind of yeah it looks like this is
just old
yeah good Cydia good you don't play that
she played instead Knight 91 he and
finally I saw this idea was a fourth
which I thought it was good and now yeah
because it's kind of put some pressure
on him I'm the knight on d5 Knight to f3
yeah I mean seems like if he wants to
fight for something the night of three
is necessary otherwise my game is just
way too easy if I manage to take Wendy
for Bishop a5 and this is h6 this is
just way too bad so he has to go for the
this material in balance don't say h6
yes I'm a BT 9 THC is not an option
right interesting
well you're expecting him to sacrifice
on f7 well yeah it's barely a sacrifice
he has three pawns yeah we looked at
this position after you guys developed a
few pieces here you put your hooks on
the e-file and I said I really like the
next position although you know you
never know but yeah like it looks like
an equal but I said no there's no way
this this game is gonna end in a draw
it happened everything but we saw this
position on the board
rookie six and Queen d2 and here I was
mentioning okay so you have a nice nice
black a deal on d5 but he almost has no
weaknesses I mean it's pretty difficult
to penetrate Weiss defense yeah yeah I
wasn't sure how to make progress here so
well my original plan was to check the
score sheet and see if he made three
moves then they do offer a draw but then
I'm like no it's the cop fighting yeah
first let's just move let's just shuffle
pieces I mean the ideal plan was to make
it to the time control and then after
move for you get another half an hour
and try to figure out what's going on
here but yeah so I was I was thinking
again tried to do like h5 h4 and see the
pretty much similar yes I thought about
which palm to push but g5 seemed to be
maybe better cuz of for you know maybe
is not support right yes so let's see
what happens to Luke Acy think again
looks and still looks pretty equal to me
it looks like you guys are waiting just
for those yeah I was just waiting here
I'm like but you see maybe I would still
prefer black here right because well I
have a piece of the roll yeah and bones
are not really connected can't really go
Bishop b6 or anything so you know in
such positions the trend is really
important you know it's like who can be
better in the long run and I guess only
black can be better in the long run
yeah it's probably good a very good
technique for viewers to know at home
that you know if you ever you don't have
to push all the time we can just like
wait for your opponents to make a
mistake yeah so king gage - looks like
you nobody's waiting here Bishop f3 and
now Queen b3 okay so we decided well why
not
and and if not quickly far then I just
don't see what he what else he can do
maybe he could have just stayed again
like King g1 or something right but then
and you never you never want to take on
e5 because maybe d5 oh maybe I want
something some point just not sure when
but also I had maybe ideas now Knight a
for because the knight is protected in
d5 yeah the pressure is coming yeah
who's putting some pressure and 25 maybe
25 is just but I don't really believe in
that move very risky right I mean to
take kind of now it's game it's game for
to results for sure so take take and
ambition g6 I thought it's pretty saw it
move I'm not sure with computer will
probably laugh at me but mission b6
well again to wait no quitter so it
wasn't so I thought I need to go bishop
g6 right and you can't take on there too
because I'm looking for something yeah
queen of two rook f1 Queen f7 and
yeah queen-to-be seven after Bishop e6 I
honestly thought that I should be in a
really good shape
well maybe even winning but that's
that's my thinking you know how does it
bring his queen better so maybe Queen d7
what so what happened take okay foine
queen bee - yeah well here after work it
must be lost for him I don't care about
g6 90s also may be the last mistake was
90s g6 maybe already here he's in the
bad shape because I want to go bishop
before now it's an actual threat or
maybe Knight e3 actually a lady three
major yeah ladies ladies coming right to
the painful yeah for sure yeah and he
only has two pawns like even if I don't
have any immediate threats I just has
too little right okay so Knight takes
here and now rook to II to begin pretty
amazing move Mr P - in a queen of seven
and he has no other chance
yeah no my kink is surprisingly really
safe from age 7 and 92 years old yeah so
if Queen f3
well after Queen f3 I actually would
have taken my G - I thought it's the
quickest way when Rosie - Rosie - takes
Queen g2 and then broke it - okay you
don't wanna think they're all consumed
oh no I mean greedy
no no no rookie - nice nice so so cool I
mean the good good for you a very good
nice good fighting spirits do you know
who I play next
we gonna be difficult just still playing
write a comment a guest I think it was a
draw draw right so okay um so yeah so
nice how used are you still doing in
school you're still in tests yeah but I
had a head rough start because I had to
submit my assignment and I hadn't like I
was a huge assignment so yeah I was
distracted quite a bit because all the
free time outside the chair so I was
just putting into it so we have to
multitask but now but now but now it's
easier because the next one is probably
due after a tournament so it's
graduation so good job and on the winter
day and good luck in your desk next
round
yep thank you for joining us thank you
and we are going to go into a quick
commercial break stay with us you don't
come back
[Music]
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like ba 3
is an illegal move here because white
bouncers point to squares not one but it
still is something we call hustle and
you can do that but you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move like
let's say play King in seven games e2
and now try because y'all play four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed at length during the course of
my stay yeah he told me this is
excellent g5 this was what I was kind of
hoping for because now I think we
practiced our noble Lawrence
this is not how chess works certainly
would be much much more fun if chess
actually work like this we don't think
it does well maybe it does well that's
me regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of my quality of life has
just gone downhill tremendously because
I'm actually sharing the office with the
guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and welcome back to st. Louis for the
2018 at st. Louis spring chess classic
Here I am Bensimon
and that is Vitaly namer and we are at
the end of round number four so during
the interview with yarrow there were a
lot of developments actually in our game
of the day in Group A we had a draw
between maruzen Akopian and alexander
ona shook and it was a game that I was
watching very intently to see if a
Cobian could pull out another miracle
oh yeah the end game you know but it was
not to be it was a draw as to be
expected when you're just looking at the
position so after four rounds of play
let's take a look at what happened here
in the standings here for the a group
yeah so it looks like Jeffrey Zhang with
the win today is still on leading with
three points and then after him we have
Alexander horn issue and version of
Cobian with two and a half points each
Sam chenkin Darius and euro terrible all
with two points and we have a few
players with a point and a half so again
the margin is not I mean still
everything is still open right I mean we
still have five more rounds to go so
even though Jeffrey is leading there are
a few leaders here but still very open
I'm not even sure that we mentioned it
but Jeffrey Zhang did defeat Ganguly
today and it was just Ganguly is
misplaced rook was too much to come back
and zhang was able to take advantage of
it
so yes the youngest player in the field
now in the top spot
so tomorrow let's take a look at what we
have in store for tomorrow's games
you'll be seeing this on us chess champs
calm remember the games start at 1:00
p.m. Central Time
we'll be on the air at 3:30 yeah we're
gonna have a lo mein Edgewood vs. Taoist
where's Alex on this ship is gonna
everything white against
same segment euros Arabic is going to
play a version accordion Jeffrey Zhang
against Lazaro bruising and Alex apado
will be playing against Surya Ganguly
yes and a word about group B you know we
only were able to view one game today we
must congratulate grandmaster JJ ali
mirandy on his victory against Jackie
Tim Bulli AK and thank him for showing
us the game it was nice to see ya lots
of sacrifices as I said that's a fire
yes at least on that one yeah elsewhere
in the round in Group E we had Andre
Corbett's taking the victory left's key
to a draw and also we know that action
genre and priyadarshan canna pan was a
draw the other results were not quite
sure of yet as of yet and we hope to
have them the function corrected
tomorrow and so we can watch all 10
games live as they happen here at us
chess jams down calm so Battaglia
final thoughts on the day yeah I mean
this was a pretty exciting day we saw
lots of decisive games and as we said
it's a now it's today's Friday by the
way so I have to celebrate yeah maybe
not too much yeah it's just beginning
for us maybe we'll celebrate the weekend
next Wednesday night yeah if you can
believe that I know it's a almost like a
we lost track of over the days I do know
that that feeling when you playing just
limit all the time it's just everyday
just a workday we're almost halfway
through this thing yeah so I think we
look forward to tomorrow and presenting
those games to you remember the round
begins at 1:00 p.m. at us chess champs
calm and through the chest 24 module the
best the best way in the world to watch
the game of chess be sure and we will be
on the air with you at 3:30 p.m. Central
so this broadcast was produced by the
world's greatest production B team Tammy
Hyatt is making sure we stay on the air
Jonathan Krantz was giving us interviews
Isaac Krantz was doing graphics and
sound our technical director is Danny
Machuca my name is Ben Simon and
Vitaliy namer and until tomorrow at 3:30
p.m. we will see you then and we say so
long from the show-me-state
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you